herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
heute ist der heißeste tag bisher in
diesem jahr 36 grad und es wird immer
heißer das mögen viele schon heute
morgen gesungen haben und mit
schweißperlen auf der stirn auf das
thermometer geblickt haben dem
thermometer beim klettern zugeschaut
haben wir reden heute über die hitze mit
unserer wetter expertin katja horneffer
wir schauen mit unserer reporterin diana
becker auf die situation in aachen da
hatten viele vorhergesagt aachen das
könnte der hotspot das könnte wohl der
heißeste ort heute werden und wir reden
mit professor jörn birkmann über die
städte wie sie mit der hitze fertig
werden über die hitze in den städten
über die probleme und was man tun kann
die hitze sie kam von westen und in den
innenstädten war sie am extremsten
vielerorts trauten sich nur noch wenige
nach draußen plätze bleiben einfach leer
wie hier in essen die größte hitze gab
es auf einer linie vom saarland über
rheinland-pfalz hessen bis nach
nordrhein westfalen mit temperaturen
vielerorts um die 38 grad duisburg
knackte den diesjährigen hitzerekord mit
39,5 grad am nachmittag in heinsberg
waren es 38 8 grad und frankfurt meldete
38,4 grad
ja wie ist das alles einzuordnen war das
jetzt ein allzeit rekord katja
das können wir natürlich jetzt noch
nicht sagen übrigens spannend dabei
finde ich dass duisburg war auch eben
2009 10 den bisherigen absoluten rekord
für deutschland eingestellt hat mit 41,2
grad damals übrigens hatte man gedacht
na ja ein solcher heißer sommer 2009 10
mit so hohen temperaturen das kommt
wahrscheinlich erst in zehn bis dreißig
jahren wieder nun keine drei jahre
später ist es schon wieder so heiß und
so ist das auch einzuordnen dass wir
immer häufiger mit solcher hitze rechnen
müssen dass diese hitzerekorde also gar
nicht lange mehr bestand haben
vielleicht ein paar jahre und dann ist
schon wieder ein neuer rekord fällig so
ist das einzuordnen tja katja du stehst
du auf dem lerchenberg hintergrund sieht
man die skyline von frankfurt dort also
auf brütende hitze haben wir heute schon
gesagt ganz kurz wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter ist das so eine kurze mini
hitzewelle die da über uns hinweg raus
oder werden wir jetzt noch viele viele
tage es extrem heiß haben
es ist so eine art hitze gipfel im
westen ist er heute schon durchgezogen
diese hitze blase die erreicht dann
morgen auch den osten dann erwarten wir
bis zu 40 grad zum beispiel in sachsen
anhalt in berlin und brandenburg
vielleicht auch in thüringen vielleicht
sogar in hamburg also 39 40 grad dass es
für dort für norddeutschland also
wirklich schon extrem ungewöhnlich noch
ungewöhnlicher als in nordrhein
westfalen oder auch in rheinland pfalz
und baden württemberg und hessen wo es
ja heute schon so heiß war das ist also
die gute nachricht aber wie wird diese
hitze weg geräumt das passiert in aller
regel immer mit tiefs und die bringen
schauer und gewitter mit so müssen wir
also morgen dann von westen mit schauern
und gewittern rechnen am späten
nachmittag und abend wie heftig die
ausfallen ist noch ein bisschen unklar
auf jeden fall wird morgen die hitze
sehr viel weniger gut zu ertragen seien
jedenfalls im westen da sie schwul wird
nämlich es kommt ja feuchte luft heran
dann gibt es diese schauer und gewitter
die in der nacht auf donnerstag dann
weiter ostwärts ziehen am donnerstag
setzt auch noch schauer und gewitter
aber danach ist es mit der ganz großen
hitze vorbei wir könnten sagen die
sommertemperaturen sind dann wieder auf
normalmaß gestuft so zwischen 18 und 32
grad ich denke das können die
allermeisten von uns dann doch etwas
besser ertragen hitze die noch
erträglich ist und normales katja wir
kommen gleich zu dir nochmal zurück in
der zwischenzeit beobachtest du mal
weiter die temperaturen ob sie doch noch
irgendwo steigen oder doch wie man es
erwarten müsste jetzt langsam sinken wie
gesagt wir kommen gleich wieder zu dir
zurück wir machen einen sprung nach
aachen denn viele hatten es vorher
gesagt eben machen das würde der hotspot
werden und jana becker unsere reporterin
hat die stadt erlebt über 38 grad auch
nicht gerade wenig jetzt bist du in
einem krankenhaus im luisenhospital jana
wie geht man denn in einem krankenhaus
mit dieser hitze um wenn man an die
patienten denken
vor der notaufnahme und vielleicht
erstmal zum abräumen wie das ja wie die
situation heute hier im krankenhaus war
die notaufnahme ist relativ leer
geblieben also der große ansturm ist
ausgeblieben
ja die menschen hier also das personal
geht vor allem davon aus dass dadurch
das amtliche warnungen vorher ja
verkündet worden dass die leute sich
darauf vorbereiten konnten und deshalb
wurden auch maßnahmen getroffen hier im
vor allem für die patienten das
reichlich wasser verteilt wurde muss
dazu sagen die räumlichkeiten sind hier
nicht klimatisiert bis auf die op säle
wobei es hier jetzt trotzdem relativ
kühles im vergleich zu den plätzen an
denen wir uns heute tagsüber aufgehalten
haben ansonsten hat man hier
ventilatoren noch aufgestellt und sich
auch darauf vorbereitet dass heute mehr
menschen die in die notaufnahme hätten
kommen können also das personal hätte
auch aufgestockt werden können ja jetzt
hast du auch noch einen experten an
mediziner ein arzt sein oberarzt an
deiner seite dann müssen wir doch von
ihm einfach mal erfahren ihn fragen was
denn diese hitze der hitzestress eben
für die patienten bedeutet worunter die
leiden was die gefahren eben sind
[Musik]
die älteren patienten und kranken
patienten natürlich extrem gefährdet
wird sich der hitze weil natürlich der
flüssigkeitshaushalt bei den patienten
sehr labil ist und die extreme achten
müssen dass ausreichende
flüssigkeitsmenge je nach krankheitsbild
ist natürlich umso wichtiger auf eine
herzschwäche vorliegt oder
nierenschwäche und dass wir da ganz
besonders achten müssen und auch die
älteren patienten achten müssen dass die
ausreichend flüssigkeit bekommen
teilweise müssen wir doch über die vene
geben je nachdem ob die patienten selber
trinken oder nicht aber die pflege ist
angehalten da gut drauf zu achten dass
sie prozent aus trinken genau ich hatte
eben kurz auch schon gesagt die ihre
räumlichkeiten sind hier jetzt nicht
klimatisiert trotzdem ist es noch ertrag
weil sich meine jungs jetzt ein großer
hit zu tag aber trotzdem verwahrung
denkt man nicht darüber nach die
räumlichkeiten zu klimatisieren und das
in patienten patienten noch erträglicher
zu machen ja das wäre natürlich schön da
denken wir denke ich auch drüber nach
das ist natürlich unseren gebäuden und
krankenhauskomplex sehr schwierig das
heißt hohe auflagen hier kritisiere die
klimaanlagen zu installieren ist dann
durch hohe hygienische auflagen auch es
sind keine unterwegs das muss alles
speziellen filtern ausgestattet werden
sodass das komplexer ist als in einer
normalen wohnung natürlich und das sind
auch häufig sehr komplexe gebäude hier
ich denke mal in zukunft muss man da
sehr ernsthaft darüber nachdenken dass
gestaltet weil er natürlich die
hitzeperioden höchstwahrscheinlich
länger und häufiger auftreten werden
naja also ja
genau das hören wir eben raus es ist
eine große belastung für ältere für
schwache menschen und dass dieser
hitzestress eben auch tödliche folgen
haben kann das halten wir uns vielleicht
alle gar nicht so sehr vor augen das
sind ist uns gar nicht so sehr bewusst
aber die zahlen die wir bekommen die
sprechen eine deutliche sprache
denn in sehr heißen sommern sind in den
vergangenen jahren tausende menschen an
den folgen der hitze gestorben diese
zahlen schätzen das rk ii der deutsche
wetterdienst und das umweltbundesamt in
einer aktuellen studie 2018 wir sehen
ist waren es demnach 8700 zusätzliche
todesfälle im zusammenhang mit
hitzewellen 2003 sogar
die frage eben an den oberarzt grebe ist
dieses ist sozusagen die totenzahlen das
eben menschen auch wirklich daran
sterben nicht einfach nur mal
kollabieren und vielleicht ein problem
haben ist das eine sache die uns
wirklich gar nicht so bewusst ist gar
nicht so bekannt ist wie viel hitze tote
es gibt
toten stelle ich jetzt gerne weiter also
ist es so ist dass so ein problem das
uns auch vor allem diese großen also die
gestiegenen zahlen jetzt auch gar nicht
gar nicht so daneben hinterkopf dass wir
die gar nicht so im hinterkopf denke
auch das ist das würde uns jetzt
wahrscheinlich zunehmen präsident dann
werden wir darüber sehr viel nachdenken
und natürlich bereich berichten dem war
der grund ist natürlich häufig auch dass
die bevölkerung älter wird dh die
demografische wandel ist in gange man
sieht viele viele alte patientin und
sehr alte patienten die im pflegeheim
wohnen aber auch teilweise zu hause
natürlich wohnen und dementsprechend die
gefahr für diese patienten hoch ist dass
ich auch so einer hitze zu versterben
jetzt haben der wie eben schon gesagt
heute einen krassen hitzetag
anschließende hitze macht auch noch vor
uns wenn wir jetzt aber darüber
nachdenken über die hitzetage oder wer
hierzu wochen die die länger anhalten
das wird ja auf uns zukommen wie kann
man sich denn da besser aufstellen oder
wie worauf muss man sich da noch
einstellen ja ich sehe man muss
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich den alltag
fast ein bisschen umkrempeln das heißt
man muss an das essen an das schlafen an
das trinkverhalten an den tag legen ich
habe da müsse einiges vielleicht
umdenken unseren köpfen stattfinden die
eltern leute brauchen mehr unterstützung
wahrscheinlich noch als wir bis jetzt
tun können das heißt nicht mehr
generation ist vielleicht auch noch mehr
gefragt die angehörigen müssen mehr
darauf achten das familiäre umfeld und
so weiter musste immer präsent sein und
einfach noch mal nachschauen dass die
not unterstützt werden sei es auch mit
zum beispiel einkaufen oder ähnlichem
wenn es wirklich wochenlang anhalten
sollte sowas
dann hoffen wir dass die macht hier auch
noch ruhig bleibt im klinikum und ihnen
auch alles gute und ich gebe zurück nach
mainz ja und wir sagen dankeschön an
beide jana vielen vielen dank an dich
und natürlich eben auch an dr julian
gräber grüße nach aachen vielen dank
zurück zu katja hornuf
die immer noch die hitze draußen direkt
miterlebt in einem klimatisierten raum
wir haben es gerade gehört von doktor
julian grebe da im luisenhospital in
aachen jahr man überlegt ja nun doch mal
ob man vielleicht doch mehr räume
klimatisiert denn und das sagt er ja
gerade es wird ja wohl das so heiß
werden ist das wirklich so dass wir so
extrem heiße tage einfach öfter und
vielleicht auch länger leben in der
zukunft haben werden
ja das ist genau das was ihr im zuge des
klimawandels einfach erwarten können
dass die hitzewellen früher kommen dass
sie größere gebiete betreffen dass es in
den hitzewellen auch heißer wird und
dass hitze werden auch mal länger
andauern wir sehen das ja gerade in
südeuropa bei uns hier in deutschland
sind diese temperaturen mit über 30 grad
ja durchaus auch als heiß zu bezeichnen
und es gibt natürlich da die
klimaszenarien also je nachdem wie wir
menschen uns verhalten wie viel co2 und
die viele treibhausgase wie in die
atmosphäre entlassen gibt es ja
verschiedene klimaszenarien die uns
sagen was bis 2100 passieren kann und da
werden dann wenn wir uns nicht
vernünftig verhalten also nicht die
treibhausgase besonders reduzieren dann
könnten eben halt jahrestemperaturen die
68 grad höher sind als bisher auftreten
und das bedeutet dann natürlich auch
dass wir doppelt so viele sommertage
haben also tage mit temperaturen von 25
grad und mehr dass wir vier mal so viele
heiße tage haben also temperaturen an
einem tag von mehr als 30 grad und das
belaste da wird wahrscheinlich der
mediziner auch zustimmen sind dann die
tropennächte die könnten sich bis zum
ende des jahrhunderts sogar
verzwanzigfachen also jetzt aktuell
haben wir so wenige tage im jahr jetzt
die kommende nacht wird ja zum beispiel
nur tropen nachdem der die temperatur
nicht unter 20 grad sinkt aber das ist
an sich für deutschland was ungewöhnlich
ist in einigen städten sind das so im
schnitt 23 vielleicht mal ja und wenn
man jetzt vor stellen müssen das wird
dann für euch zum ende des jahrhunderts
sind das 20 30 tage da werden ganz viele
menschen große probleme bekommen
schlafen zu können und das hat natürlich
auch ganz viel mit den gebäuden zu tun
dass die dann nicht mehr richtig
abkühlen aber dazu habt ihr gleich noch
einen gast den herrn bergmann genau wir
haben schon viele fragen die hier kommen
ob eben städte wie man sie bei dir im
hintergrund sieht frankfurt/duisburg da
sind ja beton landschaften schreibt hier
jemand und das hat sich nun mal auf da
muss man sich eben darauf einstellen da
kommen wir gleich noch drauf aber die
frage die sich direkt betrifft an dich
geht katja kommt von über youtube von
mensch mit wahrscheinlich zwei tage über
30 grad das ist doch keine hitzewelle
aber jetzt mal frage an dich dann haben
wir vielleicht glück dass das so in 24
stunden gegessen ist dass es eben
beschrieben dann kommt eben wieder der
regen aber wie siehst du das kann in
diesem ist es damit getan in diesem jahr
oder kann das durchaus auch noch im
august wie auch immer zu einer längeren
hitzewelle kommen
sie wir sehen ja vor allen dingen dass
es jetzt keinen flächendeckenden regen
gibt und es bleibt einfach der mund
trocken und auch wenn sie jetzt mal
vorübergehend so ein paar kräftige
schauer oder gewitter gibt die bringen
ja für die dürre und für die trockenheit
gar nichts das ist viel zu wenig und
schiesst im wesentlichen auch nur
oberflächlich ab der boden ist so
ausgedörrt dass das wasser überhaupt
nicht eindringen kann so müssen wir
einfach davon ausgehen dass es trocken
bleibt und das ist natürlich weiterhin
heiß ist also hitzewelle damit
bezeichnet wir eigentlich einen zeitraum
von mehreren tagen in denen es halt mehr
als 30 grad gibt das müssen jetzt nicht
gleich 37 38 39 oder gar 40 grad seien
aber schon mehrere tage am stück 30 grad
da können wir schon von einer hitzewelle
sprechen ganz scharf definiert ist
übrigens dieser begriff hitzewelle nicht
also ob das nun zwei oder fünf tage sein
müssen mit über 30 grad natürlich kommt
es ganz darauf an wo unser user uns
gerade zuhört denn an der küste war es
jetzt sehr lange sehr kalt und auch an
der ostseeküste gab es ja heute nur in
anführungsstrichen 25 grad da wird es
dann ja morgen auch etwas wärmer aber je
nachdem wo man in deutschland wohnt kann
man schon verstehen dass da menschen
sagen wieso so waren ist es doch bei mir
noch gar nicht gewesen so ist es hängt
wirklich davon ab wo man ist wir haben
noch eine interessante frage von sigrid
über youtube und an dich katja kann es
zukünftig auch wieder regenreiche sommer
geben oder droht uns eine wüstenbildung
in deutschland die anderenorts in europa
zum beispiel rumänien
also betrachten wir mal die letzten paar
jahre 2018 war ja wirklich ein sehr
dünner sommer 2009 10 fast genauso durch
2020 auch nochmal der ausreißer war
jetzt eigentlich 20 21 bewusst mal mehr
geregnet hat wir denken an die
schreckliche katastrophe an a und erft
und in diesem jahr scheint es wieder ein
dürre sammer zu werden was steckt
dahinter das ist die globale zirkulation
können wir sagen einfach dadurch dass
wir häufiger solche stagnierenden
wetterlagen haben und wenn diese
stagnierenden wetterlagen eben mal
ungünstig sitzen wie zum beispiel im
vergangenen jahr mitte juli also so
kräftige regenfälle über viele tage bei
uns gab dann kann es natürlich auch bei
uns wieder länger andauernden
niederschlag geben die
wahrscheinlichkeit aber dass wir
häufiger solche hitzewellen haben steigt
einfach mit jedem grad der
klimaerwärmung und dazu vielleicht noch
global haben wir jetzt war so 1,1 1,2
grad bei uns in deutschland sind das ja
schon 1,7 1,8 grad also wir hier in
deutschland haben ja das pariser
klimaziel längst gerissen ich weiß nicht
ob das jedem unserer user unserer
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer so klar ist
also wir sind schon mitten im
klimawandel angekommen
du hast es eben ja selbst formuliert man
muss sich das einmal vor augen halten es
ist nicht lange her 2009 10 wird sich
daran erinnern gab es den bisherigen
hitzerekord
41,2 grad eben auch gemessen in duisburg
und da hat man sich gesagt so eine
jahrhunderthitze bis man so was wieder
kriegt naja das dauert mindestens 20
jahre oder 15 jahre und nun sind wir
ganz ganz nah oder ist die gleiche stadt
sogar duisburg wieder ganz ganz nah an
diesen rekord dran gekommen jetzt fragt
entsprechend tinnemeyer sind den
temperaturen wenn man erstmal weiter
spinnt und sagt also immer höhere
temperaturen sind möglich sind den
temperaturen wie in kanada von mehr als
50 grad eines tages möglich
will ich nicht ausschließen das sehe ich
jetzt nicht für die nächsten sagen wir
mal 30 40 jahre also das was wir
übersehen können glaube ich nicht dass
wir temperaturen an die 49 grad hier in
spitzen bekommen das ist schon sehr
außergewöhnlich so einer hitze von 41 42
grad aber wie schon gesagt man kann sich
da täuschen es war ja auch schon so dass
man 2003 gedacht hat das ist jetzt ein
jahrhundertsommer sowas kommt nie wieder
in diesem jahrhundert und 2018 gerade
mal 15 jahre später kam der nächste
jahrhundert sommer also auszuschließen
ist das nicht aber die bedingungen sind
bei uns hier in mitteleuropa dann doch
etwas andere als da in kanada wir haben
ja hier eine richtig funktionierende
vegetation noch und wenn wir da auch
häufiger darauf achten dass wir klima
angepasste pflanzen anbauen dann denke
ich werden wir das wasser regime in
deutschland dahingehend bringen dass wir
nicht solche hohen temperaturen haben
denn die bekommt man ja eigentlich nur
wenn eben halt die vegetation nicht
genügend feuchtigkeit noch verdunsten
kann aber du sagst es schon klima
angepasste pflanzen das heißt ist es so
dass wir sage ich mal jetzt in mainz am
ende ein klima haben wir in der adria
und dann eben entsprechende pflanzen
hier gut wachsen
ja ganz genau dazu gibt es ja diese
sogenannte zwillingsstudien zwillings
städte in europa das hat das
umweltbundesamt mal herausgefunden oder
mal berechnet da kann man ganz schön
sehen welches klima zum beispiel
bremerhaven in ende des jahrhunderts
haben wird das wäre dann so irgendwo in
der bretagne ja oder mainz das wäre dann
irgendwo an der adria das heißt unser
unser klima wenn wir wissen wollen wie
sieht's denn nun aus in 50 60 jahren das
interessiert uns einfach dann müssen wir
zum beispiel nach südfrankreich fahren
oder nach oberitalien je nachdem wo wir
in deutschland boden ist ja klar je
weiter wir im norden boden desto
gemäßigt da wird die hitze noch sein und
je weiter wir im süden oder auch im
südwesten deutschlands leben desto eher
wird das eben dieses südeuropäische ja
subtropische klima seien mit sehr viel
hitze und mit den enormen waldbränden
und wir haben ja auch heute wieder in
deutschland einige busch oder
böschungsbrände gehabt also auch bei uns
geht es eben in richtung
dann danken wir ganz ganz herzlich katja
für seine erklärungen auch ein bisschen
die voraussicht und auch noch mal die
mahnenden worte dass wir dieses
klimaziel eigentlich schon gerissen
haben das muss man sich auch noch mal
vor augen führen was wir sozusagen heute
hier erleben katja vielen vielen dank
dass du uns berichtet hast so und wir
schauen jetzt weiter wir haben es schon
angeschnitten mehrfach die hitze in den
städten sind vor allen dingen das große
problem wir wollen darüber weiterreden
mit professor jörn birkmann dem leiter
des instituts für raumordnung und
entwicklungsplanung an der universität
stuttgart bevor wir aber mit dem
professor über die anpassung der städte
an die hitze sprechen ein beispiel
nämlich die stadt freiburg
skifahren verboten aber fürs skifahren
ist diese wiese auch nicht angelegt das
dach einer sporthalle in freiburg ist
beispiel dafür die gebäude sich der
klima erwärmung anpassen können susanne
knospe ist projektleiterin des klima
anpassungs konzept sind freiburg zum
konzept gehören auch tiefer gelegte
pflanzen bäte das gehört zu dem schwamm
stadt konzept der klimawandel zeigt wir
haben immer weniger wasser und das ist
unterschiedlich verteilt die städte
müssen ein schwamm werden der das wasser
aufnimmt und dann abgibt wenn es regnet
läuft das wasser in das beet und wässert
den baum der baum liefert schatten und
verdunstungskühlung und diese kühle
braucht die stadt das demonstriert
susanne knospen an dem stein der
stundenlang in der sonne lag in der
nacht würde diese wärme auch abgeben das
ist der städtische wärme insel effekt
den wir nur in griff kriegen wenn mir
sowas haben nämlich bäume bäume bäume
bäume alle paar meter wurden buchen
gepflanzt für das klima grund für den
schatten hitzetage sind nicht nur in
zubetonierten innenstädten ein problem
sondern deutschlandweit
diese hitze entlastung die der mensch
braucht das ist ja so ein dreiklang ja
was braucht man was hilft bei hitze des
wind das wasser und dieses schatten und
diese drei punkte die finden sich auch
in einer stadt im öko und vorzeigestadt
teil wobei hat man die hitze gut im
griff begrünte dächer alter baumbestand
und pflanzen an den fassaden sorgen für
abkühlung hitze hotspots sind weiterhin
die innenstädte der wassermangel ist
auch hier zu spüren noch laufen die
brunnen auch sie sind teil des konzepts
um sich abzukühlen
das war das beispiel freiburg jetzt
gehen wir aber nach stuttgart zu
professor jörn birkmann folgenden tag
vielen dank dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben
guten abend
herr professor die hitze macht uns vor
allen in den städten zu schaffen jetzt
haben wir gerade gehört wind wasser
schatten gegen die hitze das ist das
rezept wie kriegt man das hin was muss
man tun
ich glaube die große herausforderung ist
dass auf der einen seite natürlich eine
wohnungsknappheit haben und auch städte
wachsen und dementsprechend brauchen wir
neues bauland auf der anderen seite
sieht man natürlich dass gerade wind
wasser und grünflächen verschattete
flächen das sind natürlich flächen auch
im freiraum dazu brauchen wir parks da
brauchen wir im grunde kaltluft
schneisen die vom umland der städte bis
in die innenstadt reichen und das sind
natürlich immer auch herausforderungen
in diesem kontext wie baue ich und wobei
ich und wie stark muss ich eigentlich
auch grünbereiche qualifizieren also
alleine in ausgeräumt hacker reicht ja
nicht für die kühlung sondern hier muss
man ja wirklich auch parkanlagen blaue
infrastrukturen wie wasser etc sichtbar
und erfahrbar machen sie sagen es jetzt
also mehr schatten mehr grünflächen sie
sagen qualifiziert also mit bäumen nicht
einfach eine brachliegende ackerfläche
das brauchen wir aber sie haben gerade
gesagt wir brauchen mehr wohnraum da
gibt es immer das wort des verdichters
aber das hat ja auch gewisse probleme
erklären sie das mal
ja wir haben schon das ziel natürlich
jetzt auch auf bundesebene auch in
vielen bundesländern natürlich
verdichteten wohnungsbau zu betreiben
das heißt also hier auch
mehrfamilienhäuser zu bauen möglichst
verdichtetes wohnen im sinne von flächen
sparen das muss aber auch einher gehen
mit zum beispiel qualitätsvollen
grünanlagen das heißt also wenn wir
jetzt zum beispiel über berlin mal
nachdenken in der berliner innenstadt
eine verdichtete bauweise da kann man
sicherlich nicht ganz die innenstadt
begrünen aber sicherlich im umfeld der
innenstadt im angebote schaffen für
verschüttete bereiche weil man selber in
der wohnung eben zu wenig möglichkeiten
dann sicherlich auch hat und man möchte
auch nicht das leben mit einer
klimaanlage in solchen hitzestress tagen
nur in der wohnung verbringen das hatten
wir schon genug in kobe zeiten und hier
ist eben wichtig daneben verdichtete
bauweise mit qualitäten bereich zu
fördern und man muss natürlich aufpassen
wer kann sich bestimmte
anpassungsmaßnahmen leisten das ist
heute sicher auch ein thema also nicht
nur fragen wie heißt es sondern wie
neben unterschied bevölkerungsgruppen
auch diese hitze war und welche
anpassungs kapazitäten haben
unterschiedliche stadtteile oder
bevölkerungsgruppen
dann nehmen wir doch einfach mal das
beispiel was sie gerade genannt haben
berlin sie haben freundlicherweise uns
einfach mal karten zur verfügung
gestellt da können wir uns das einfach
mal anschauen ganz deutlich ist grün da
ist es also prima pink da ist es extrem
heiß und es ist jetzt nicht ganz
überraschend dass es eben im absoluten
zentrum berlins in mitte eben ganz
extrem heiß ist nun gibt es müssen sie
einfach mal erklären wir haben oft
gerade in dem beitrag gehört da reizt es
sich extrem auf und beton asphalt etc
herr professor halten eben auch die
hitze heißt das ebenso die karte ist
jetzt nicht nur am nachmittag sondern
auch daneben nachts ist es dort extrem
heiß
ja für berlin steht im grunde
stellvertretend für viele deutsche aber
auch internationale städte gleiches
phänomen haben in paris oder in london
oder new york die innenstadt kühlt im
grunde in der nacht nicht ab wenn nicht
starke kaltluft aus dem umland rhein
fließt und dieser hitze insel effekt
dass es zum teil zehn grad heißer in
diesen innenstädten noch ist als im
umland dass es sicherlich gerade für
diese innenstädte von bedeutung wir
sehen aber auch an dem beispiel berlin
dass sie zum beispiel marzahn
hellersdorf große bereiche haben oder in
lichtenberg die auch diese pink
schraffur haben oder die pink farbe das
sind zum teil gewerbegebiete können sie
ja sagen das ist nur beim arbeiten dann
problem aber gerade wenn sich auch im
wohnbereich handelt muss man hier
natürlich überlegen wie kann man auch
tagsüber diese hitze in diesen
wohnbereichen reduzieren und das heißt
zum beispiel auch hier wieder angebote
erreichbarkeit von grünflächen aber
vielleicht auch die wiederherstellung
von bestimmten bächen oder sogenannten
blauen perlen wird in berlin diskutiert
und auch die entwicklung ist wichtig sie
nannten das beispiel duisburg hermann
strukturwandel hier gehen bestimmte
industriezweige weg wir haben natürlich
auch flächen die man anders nutzen kann
wo man diese erholung standorte oder
erhöhungs qualitäten auch schaffen kann
dann sind wir gerade auf der karte eben
auch so kleine blaue pfeile gesehen
vielleicht klären sie das sind das dann
diese frischluftschneisen
genau das sind meistens kaltluft
schneisen wo eben kaltluft im sinne also
jetzt bei dieser hitze natürlich immer
relativ gerade beim am abend in der
nacht situation kaltluft oft aus dem
umland in die stadt einfließt und die
bebauung solcher kaltluft schneisen die
verbauung egal ob frei wo ich in
stuttgart oder in berlin ist natürlich
ein besonderes problem weil dadurch die
städte weiter aufheizen das heißt also
hier ist es wichtig natürlich dass auch
städte das jetzt zunehmend nutzen und
nicht nur oder wie früher manchmal eben
sagen klima ist wichtig aber dann im
grunde diese bereiche dann doch bebauen
und es sind natürlich eine
herausforderung weil natürlich auch
gerade die in verdichtung als das bauen
in dem stadtbereich eine wichtige
zielsetzung ist aber dementsprechend
muss man eben auch überlegen was haben
wir für bauform beispielsweise in berlin
ist eine blockrandbebauung wo man dann
in hof hat er sehr ruhig ist aber block
brand heißt dass es im grunde wie so ein
schloss ummantelt ist und hier sind
vielleicht andere bauweisen besser auf
stelzen oder die gebäude stellung ist
entscheidend dafür ob diese kaltluft
noch weiter in die stadt hinein strömt
jetzt
haben sie eine sache schon angesprochen
sie haben gesagt das hängt auch der sehr
viel davon ab ob es eben pink ist oder
grün also ob es extrem heiß wird oder
nicht wer wie viel geld hat wer wo wohnt
jetzt haben wir das beispiel auf der
karte gerade gesehen überraschen nicht
nur mitte sondern eben auch marzahn
extrem heißt erklären sie vielleicht
einfach mal was hat es denn mit der
bebauung zu tun verstehe ich jetzt
richtig dass vielleicht die platte sich
eher aufheizt als ein kleines häuschen
mit garten in wilmersdorf oder wo auch
immer
ja zumindest ist also gerade wenn man
die karten betrachtet ist das ja der
aussenraum auch vielfach das sind dann
die versiegelten flächen wenn er also
platte mit großen parkplätzen
versiegelten raum ist dann wird sich das
sicherlich auch ein heizen oder sehr
stark aufheizen im vergleich zum
beispiel zu einfamilienhaus gebieten im
bereich grunewald oder unter marzahn
gibt es auch bereiche die durch
einfamilienhaus oder geprägt sind die
eben nicht pink sind in der berliner
karte beispielsweise und da sehen wir
natürlich auch das abbild in anderen
städten das heißt jetzt nicht dass nicht
einfamilienhausbesitzer auch an
betreiben müssen aber der unterschied
ist schon dass man sicherlich als stadt
als öffentliche hand auch hier gerade
die leute besonders auch im blick haben
muss die sich einen eigenen garten gar
nicht leisten können und die dann
trotzdem neben ihrer wohnung im grunde
und kühlen raum in der nähe brauchen
also zugang zu grünflächen wasserflächen
etc
jetzt haben wir eine sache die haben wir
alle gerade zusammen in dem beitrag ganz
zum schluss gesehen da waren so einige
grünpflanzen an der fassade in freiburg
auch ein beispiel kleinere maßnahmen und
das beschäftigt hier auch einige
witze oder schreibt als kommentar über
youtube es gibt tolle moos und algen
kühlungs anlagen für städte in
litfaßsäulen und hauswänden wenn man
davor steht ist es auf zehn grad kühler
also moos algen und ein anderer fragt
schafft die konsequente begrünung thema
nochmal eine konsequente begrünung von
dächern oder hauswänden erleichterung
wäre der gesetzgeber vielleicht am ende
gut beraten das sogar verpflichtend
vorzuschreiben
ja herr meier hat sicherlich recht dass
auch die begrünung von einzelgebäuden
bedeutsam ist aber es kühlt meistens das
einzelgebäude oder die person die
entlang dieser fassade gehen was wir
brauchen sind in große grün schneisen
die diese kaltluft aus dem umland in die
stadt hinein tragen egal ob er über
berlin über bonn über stuttgart sprechen
also das würde jetzt nicht allein mit
einer wo mooswald funktionieren und hier
muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
dass man nicht plötzlich sagt eine moos
wand oder so eine vertikale ist grün hat
die gleiche funktion wie ein park sie
werden sich schwerlich in
anführungszeichen über den nachbarbalkon
irgendwie auf so eine vertikale mooswald
legen können aber im park können sich
natürlich schon auf eine decke legen das
heißt die funktion ist hier sicherlich
auch wichtig aber ein kühlungseffekt
haben auch die fassaden aber ich glaube
man brauchen mindestens auch diese
offenen bereichen brauchen sie gelungen
also wenn wir über duisburg sprechen
haben wir große bereiche wo man
eigentlich auch flächen entwickeln
sollte und konnte und teilweise auch
gemacht hat
also kritik so ein bisschen an
ja die planungen und was städte eben
machen gibt es auch hier über youtube da
schreibt jemand ich sehe oft dass den
städten sinnlose anlagen wie
springbrunnens kulturen et cetera
aufgestellt werden warum werden in
zeiten des klimawandels nicht access
bäume gepflanzt gerade in städten werden
da eben auch viele fehler gemacht dass
man das noch gar dass das noch gar nicht
so angekommen ist das was sie was wir
eben auch im beitrag gesehen haben wie
wichtig eben das ist schattenspendende
bäume die eben auch wasser halten und
was er abgeben können
also bäume sind auch wichtig und
natürlich gerade für die stadt mit
spendung wichtig gerade wenn man über
das thema wieder richtung marzahn
hellersdorf nachdenken also diese tag
situation die hitze da würde die
verschattung ein ganz wichtiger beitrag
sein weil natürlich die hitzegrade
mittags durch das die direkte
sonneneinstrahlung wirkt aber der
ja der der zuschauer hat auch in teilen
recht aber man muss vorsichtig sein auch
in anführungszeichen
springbrunnen oder so zerstäuber können
ja auch ihre wirkung haben sind
vielleicht als kinderspielplätze
relevant also ich würde das jetzt nicht
abtun auch ein guter springbrunnen der
jetzt nicht so 60er jahre nur zum
angucken ist sondern wo man wasser
erleben kann kann wichtiger kühler ort
sein kann ja auch ein erlebnis sein und
kann qualität in stetten bedeuten also
alles so museal nur bäume und
irgendwelche wasserflächen wo man sich
rein kommt das finde ich nicht so gut
wir haben sie eben schon angesprochen
sie sagen begrünungen etc helfen dem
gebäude aber jetzt nicht vielleicht eben
allen wie es das mit klimaanlagen ist
das auch so derjenige der in dem haus
drin sitzt wo die klimaanlage ballert
sehr schön kühl aber da draußen kommt
die warme luft ist das sinnvoll oder ist
dass am ende auch ein problem
jeder sicherlich eine herausforderung
auf der einen seite jetzt gerade bei dem
hitzestress das hatten sie auch glaube
ich in dem beitrag aachen jetzt im
krankenhaus da helfen klimaanlagen
natürlich kurzfristig auch stark aber
sie sind auch zu einem erheblichen teil
natürlich für die weitere abwärme in der
stadt verantwortlich das heißt gerade in
asiatischen städten auch in australien
gibt es da zu zahlen und auch so wie
jetzt in deutschland steige ich das an
also die zunehmende verwendung von
klimaanlagen führt zumindest auch zu
einer teilweise weiteren erwärmung der
stadt selber der außenräume und das ist
natürlich nicht besonders zuträglich für
leute die es nicht leisten können oder
wenn jemand eben außerhalb seiner seiner
wohnung oder seines hauses dann wieder
rausgeht kann das eben zusätzlich hitze
bedeutet fifa natürlich auch
zusätzlichen energieverbrauch
also manche verletzung vielleicht
trotzdem ist es natürlich wichtig dass
man hier die möglichkeiten auch der der
kühlung nutzt also in altersheimen
besonders verwundbare gruppen die in den
weiterer vorgaben auch kindergärten auch
in teilen bei transportmitteln da ist
natürlich eine klimaanlage auch
notwendig man muss eben aufpassen es ist
nicht eine wirkliche
tiefgehende nachhaltige lösungen sondern
muss hier sicherlich auch aufpassen dass
man nicht plötzlich die außenluft weiter
aufheizt jetzt gibt es noch eine tolle
idee
die gebe ich mal weiterhin kommentar von
wanda lustiger wenn man doch alles
zubetoniert ist es doch klar dass die
wärme gespeichert wird wir haben das
eben gesehen von der expertin in
freiburg die sagte hier dieser stellen
erhält die wärme und gibt sie dann eben
wieder ab aber anstatt sich über diese
wärme zu beschweren könnte man diese
energie doch nutzen und solarpaneele im
asphalt integrieren ich bin kein
techniker wäre das eine städtebauliche
maßnahme die was bringt
da bin ich auch zu wenig techniker aber
ich glaube fast dass die frage dann
natürlich wäre auch was passiert wenn
bestimmte panel dann kaputt gehen bei
straßen oder auf öffentlichen plätzen
mehr als schwarz ist das hat sich ja
ungeheuer auf da können sie sicher ein
kleinkind dann nicht mehr barfuß
überlaufen lassen ob das so unser ziel
sein sollte darf ich schon sagen machen
diese vertikalen wende also die
klassischen hauswände mehr sind um da
solche solarpaneelen zu realisieren oder
an den trassen entlang von autobahnen
wird es ja aktuell diskutiert oder ein
lärmschutzwällen also da würde mir doch
andere standorte als prioritär einfahren
als jetzt überall auf gehwegen oder
plätzen zu installieren gerade wenn sie
so schwarz sind dann ist seine enorme
temperatur da können sie ja fast in
anführungszeichen ihr picknick mit dem
grill organisieren das spiegelei drauf
prozent jetzt ist klar geworden also wir
haben mehrfach gesagt wind wasser
schatten ganz wichtige sachen gegen die
hitze aber die frage ist ja eigentlich
wie viel wird getan und wie realistisch
ist es dann ganz einfach wenn sie jetzt
hingehen und sagen ja da müsste man sie
sagen es ja gerade in duisburg da müsste
man doch sozusagen wieder
umfunktionieren grünflächen machen wo
vorher vielleicht eine fabrik war wenn
aber jetzt zum
oberbürgermeister in duisburg jemand
hinkommt und sagt ich bei euch da eine
neue fabrik in die schafft arbeitsplätze
wie ist das denn ist es dann am ende so
dass die arbeitsplätze dann doch den
klima gedanken schlagen und am ende die
fabrik entsteht und gerne grünfläche
das war sicherlich in der vergangenheit
stark auch der fall dass man sicherlich
hier auch die arbeitsplätze priorisiert
hat wir haben wir jetzt glaube ich auch
so zehn jahre boom phase hinter uns
nicht in allen regionen aber da sind
städte stark gewachsen auch
wirtschaftswachstum vielfach ich glaube
die einsicht ist gestiegen also alle
großstädte wenig bekannt sind auch
duisburg ist übrigens auch sehr
engagiert in dem bereich klimaanpassung
also da sind schon auch ganz andere
ziele heute vorhanden als dass man das
früher diskutiert hat und der
klassischen ökologische stadt der
zukunft in aachen der 80er zum beispiel
also hier hat sich schon was verändert
und ich glaube es gehört heute auch zur
schaffung von lebensqualität hier zum
beispiel qualitativ hochwertige
grünräume zu haben erholungsräume also
das ist ja auch ein attraktivität
merkmal von städten aber es ist auch
richtig wenn man richtung logistik
denken da haben wir natürlich vielfach
auch große hallen große zugeteilte
bereiche wieder die sicherlich dieses
ziel konterkarieren wir haben aber auch
eine chance wir haben über den online
handel immer geklagt bzw gesagt die
innenstädte im grunde
ja gehen so ein bisschen im grunde
richtung leerstand und hier kann man
natürlich auch umbau betreiben es muss
ja nicht jede fußgängerzone nur mit
geschäften besetzten man kann sich auch
zum beispiel gebäude auf stelzen
vorstellen wenn dadurch die kaltluft am
boden durch das gebäude im grunde
hindurchgehen kann in die innenstadt das
wäre vielleicht auch mal innovativ also
hier glaube ich eröffne sich auch
chancen und ich glaube das thema hat an
zunehmender bedeutung auch gewonnen und
wird jetzt nicht mehr nur als ein sohn
umweltbelange nirgendwo abgehakt also
das ganze wird schon etwas ernster
genommen es gibt noch eine interessante
frage von fabi 93 auf youtube gibt es
denn konzepte zur wasserverteilung denke
gerade an rhein main und die probleme im
vogelsberg und rhön die den eigenen
bedarf kaum noch decken können wir
sprechen jetzt über hitze in den städten
aber ist das eben auch ein punkt dass es
manche städte und orte gibt wo eben die
wasserverteilung großes problem ist
das ist sicherlich so also die hitze
erleben wir jetzt gerade das ist ja auch
hier der kern beitrag aber natürlich
geht die hitze auch vielfach mit dürren
einher also mit weniger wasser auch im
kontext der klimaerwärmung werden im
februar auch den arbeitsbericht der
arbeitsgruppe 2 des weltklimarats
veröffentlicht also es ist sehr deutlich
dass auch hier zum beispiel das thema
durch eine rolle spielt nicht ist
natürlich die herausforderungen wie
gehen sie dann mit neuen baumpflanzungen
um die viel wasser brauchen oder wenn
der grundwasserspiegel absenken oder
wenn bäche austrocknen das sind
natürlich herausforderungen die auch
jetzt gerade eine stadt regionale
kooperation erfordern weil viele städte
natürlich auf ihrem eigenen
gemeindegebiet dieses wasser problem
nicht alleine lösen können
was wird zum abschluss eigentlich mal
alles zusammen was wir jetzt gerade
gelernt haben katja horneffer hat
deutlich gemacht dass die zahl der
extrem heißen tage halt immer mehr
zunimmt dass wir wirklich den
klimawandel haben und dass wir uns
eigentlich vor augen führen müssen dass
die zunahme die temperaturzunahme in
deutschland eigentlich schon längst eine
1,5 gerissen hat dass wir also nun
wirklich eine steigende temperaturen
steigen die temperaturen hier haben wir
haben aus dem krankenhaus gehört es ist
eine belastung eben für die älteren und
sie haben gesagt oder bringen ja
beispiele dafür dass wir umplanen
umdenken müssen wie ist ihr eindruck
sind wir bei diesem umdenken umplanen
von stetten schnell genug oder zu
langsam
ja das ist im grunde so eine ähnliche
auch frage wie beim aufbau nach einer
flutkatastrophe ist man schnell genug
oder nicht aber ich glaube man hat
konzepte die jetzt noch stärker im
grunde in den vorschein treten und
sicherlich auch einer stärkeren
umsetzung bedürfen man bräuchte aber
auch noch mehr pilotvorhaben also wie
kann man wirklich zum beispiel auch
gebäude aber auch landnutzung zukünftig
was ja früher auch kam mit dem thema
schwalmstadt hier so ausrüsten das
wasser gespeichert wird aber dass auch
qualitativ hochwertige freiflächen
entstehen wo man sich gerne aufhält auch
bei solchen heißen tagen und wo man
abwechslung zu einem leben unter co
wittmann bedingungen in einer einzelnen
wohnung schafft also das ist glaube ich
schon deutlich und ich glaube es zeigt
sich auch dass das thema klimawandel bei
vielen in der privatwirtschaft in der
kommunalpolitik auch angekommen ist also
hier gibt es sehr viele städte die auch
sagen dass thema nutze ich um deutlich
zu machen wir sind hier aktiv also das
ist denke ich mal doch auch ein gutes
zeichen ich hoffe wir sind auf dem
richtigen weg aber vielleicht eine
anmerkung noch dazu ist es auch so die
baulandpreise sprechen dagegen also wenn
sie jetzt heute ein grundstück kaufen
können als investor in bestimmten
bereichen bauen dann werden sie im
grunde auch etwas
mikroökonomisch schwierig wenn sie
plötzlich sagen ich lasse die hälfte der
fläche umgebaut also hier ist absolut
auch dass die notwendigkeit von seiten
der stadt der länder auch das
bundesvorgaben und impulse zu setzen
dass diese nachhaltige und klima
angepasst der stadtentwicklung voran
schreitet dann wollen wir das sozusagen
hoffen wenigstens doch noch ein kleiner
optimistischer ausblick und eine gewisse
mahnung ganz herzlichen dank professor
jörn birkmann vielen dank und grüße nach
stuttgart ja das war zdf heute live zum
das können wir nun sagen bisher
heißesten tag in deutschland in diesem
jahr mit
39,5 grad am nachmittag in duisburg der
absoluten hitzerekord ist damit noch
nicht gerissen aber katja hornuf hat es
deutlich gemacht es ist ernst und es
kann auch in diesem sommer noch weitere
heiße tage geben noch längere
hitzewellen als das was wir im moment
erleben wir haben das ganze eingeordnet
was bedeutet das eben auch für schwache
alte menschen im krankenhaus und was
müssen städte tun um die hitze die das
große problem vor allen dingen in den
städten sind ist zu bekämpfen das war
zdf heute live zu diesem thema vielen
dank für das interesse des und einen
schönen etwas kühleren abend noch tief